على الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه اعلن
حزب الله انه نفذ ع عمليات ضد مواقع
وتجمعات اسرائيليه قباله الحدود الجنوبيه
للبنان وقال الحزب انه استهدف بصواريخ
كورنيت دبابه اسرائيليه في موقع رويست
العاصي ما ادى الى تدميرها ووقوع طاقمها
بين قتيل وجريح كما اعلن الحزب قصفه عددا
من المواقع الاسرائيليه بينها ثكنه زرعيت
بصواريخ بركان واستهدافه تجمعات عسكريه
اسرائيليه جنوب مستوطنه المناره وفي موقع
المالكيه وموقع الرادار الاسرائيلي في
مزارع شبعه المحتله هذا وشنت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه غارات استهدفت منطقه
اللبونه كما قصفت مسيره اسرائيليه محيط
بلده الهبار وقصفت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
محيطه اكثر من ع بلدات حدوديه في جنوب
لبنان i